hey everyone
super excited to share with you adi
ashanti's emptiness dancing
adiasanti has been a
profound influence on my life and many
others
he's an incredible author an incredible
spiritual synthesis
and just distills the exact essence so
punctually
i'm still aiming to figure out how to
optimally go through these
with you
because there's a lot
of notes
and
it can take a long
time to get through all of them
so
what i'm feeling is most optimal is to
go through
the book with you
and specifically the core
core highlights like the cream cream of
the crop
the creme de la creme
and
and then we'll continue to figure out
how to optimally
hone in on the most efficient way to
distill what we're reading
the essence of what we're reading the
cream of what we're reading
and
if you have any insights into how you
feel it would be optimal to distill
the core
essence
let us know in the comments below
because there are things like these core
highlights there are things like
these
and there's a lot of highlighting
as well so they're start segments
so let us know in the comments below if
you have any insights into how to
optimally
do these
book
video
disseminations of the core essence
and we'll keep it
iterating and improving on this process
to better
serve
all of you guys all of
you lovely
viewers
you lovely subscribers you lovely
humans that i adore so much
because you are me and i am you this is
all oneness and i'm so excited to go
through this
the emptiness dancing
all right i hope this
profoundly positively influences you
cool love moves without an agenda
the direct experience of who we are
a fierce hunger to no ultimate truth
this is the core a dissolution of
attachment to any personal identity
disarming and deconstruction of the
personal identity
so
silence do nothing and uncontrived
thought-free wakefulness
naturally arises
so just notice
more and more often
in your direct experience what happens
when you're silent and when you're not
doing anything
you'll notice discursive thinking and
then over time you'll notice that it
quiets and as patanjali said two
thousand years ago
that
yogas chitta virti nirodha
union
with god
is simply the cessation
the quieting of the fluctuations of mind
and then right there you'll see it an
empty cognizance a no thing
right there
and then the whole game is just to go
back to that
back to that suchness back to that
oneness back to that no thingness
over and over and over again recognize
that that's all this is
and it can be hard because the mind
wants to go do things wants to be busy
but see what happens when you're silent
and you do nothing
and if you want to really add another
component to it then fast
fasting is another great component to it
fast for 12 hours fast for 24 hours and
see how that augments
the practice
awakening from the dream state of
separateness to the reality of the one
enlightenment means waking up to what
you truly are and then being that
realize and be realize and be
i love that realize and be realize and
be be it live it
the truth is that you are already
what you are seeking
you are looking for god with his eyes
love that
has the one awakened to itself
only the crazy ones stay
in terms of
the pursuit of truth
fiercely
another great question what is it that
hears this sound
and that's that empty cognizance the
mind nature the mind essence it's empty
cognizance just turn
it on itself
consciousness was
unconfined to the form
boom
two different aspects i'm everything i'm
absolutely nothing this was the
awakening the realization of capital s
self
it's an
unidentified a weakness such a good way
to put it
stop binding consciousness or spirit to
our thoughts and mental states
and so when you're no longer functioning
through your conditioning the sense of
me who is living that life is no longer
there
separate self dissolves
awakeness free of all identity
love it awakeness free of all identity
so mind being this virtual reality
thought
generator and eternal awakeness realizes
itself
truth is who you are without your story
or script right now
awakening is a radical shift in identity
you are eternal being
only the people who don't know who they
are are the ones who are awake
awakeness
is to have no script
awakening is the realization that
happens after the mind says i give up
i just have no idea who i am
being cannot be fixated
the best altar of all would have nothing
on it
you are not a human being you are being
appearing as human
thy will be done
to welcome the mystery of your own being
is satsang
when you kill i am human that's
awakening awakening from chasing maya is
lucky
because damn maya is hella intoxicated
self-image is suffering non-openness
realization of the truth removes the
limited me there is suddenly no
self-image but only total presence
infant-like fascination with movement in
your senses and what is present in the
world
childlike but absolutely wise
one whole perceiving itself
if you can
attend to this activity frequently
this will really help accelerate things
always perceive it as one whole
perceiving itself one whole experiencing
itself one whole dancing with itself
playing with itself
in a symphony with itself
the hole that perceives itself
wisdom innocence love
we see an unbelievable miracle that
anything exists at all is seen as an
absolute and utter miracle
i like to use the gladiator meme here
are you not entertained
look at all this
see universe
earth
life
your existence
are you not entertained this miracle
the more we realize that there isn't a
self the more intimately present we
actually are
it's bypassing thought when it relates
to experience
we no longer relate from the personal
sense of me but from the whole of
existence
awakening reveals
that there is no personal self and that
everything is myself
yum
so you untie the neuro knot
so no i me or self
and then you get nothing everything you
get energy doing work
and that wisdom innocence and love play
into each other and this is pure service
and feel free as you're going through if
you're finding segments that you're
really enjoying just pause the video
take some notes yourself about the
specific segment
and then also if you really liked that
part just drop it in the comments below
and share it with other people
build that community
fam
true enlightenment is when matter and
spirit are in harmony
non-differentiation or oneness
the truth is the only thing you'll ever
run into that has no agenda
as nasa godzilla maharash said i am the
supreme source of all
and that's from siddhar meshwar maharaj
his guru
which he pondered until he knew it was
true until he became it
and if you haven't yet highly recommend
reading i am that one of the best
spiritual books of all time
it's really important to get to the
point of maturity where you are willing
to look at what is fundamental to pull
your identification as a limited self
out by the root you must look at in the
most fundamental way
so this is finding the root of who you
are what is the root of this location
called me
in that movement from innocent
fascination to identification that is
where freedom is lost
and so here's a
pretty cute way
of visualizing it
so you have the human moth
that flies in to
the unconditionally free singularity
dissolving and becoming
that so it's cutting through the
clouds
and recognizing oneself as the sun and
you use the question who am i as your
self-inquiry and then you only
look as the mystery itself
there is a very awake alive and loving
mystery and that's what is seeing
through your eyes at this moment
when you deeply know that you are the
mystery experiencing itself you realize
that's all that is ever happening
the mystery experiencing itself
extending itself into time and form
that's all that is happening
release rigidity control of the mystery
moving you
all self-image disappears in order for
that body to be totally
to totally live the mystery knowingly
its personal agenda has to be completely
dissolved
beingness sees more and more thoroughly
that the only thing that actually exists
is itself it's a visceral thing
there is nothing to hold on to no
viewpoints to hold no separation the
truth sets you free the whole being has
to realize the truth it has to be the
truth knowingly
this means to wake up and find out what
you eternally are
instead of trying to manage your
neuroses
when you don't seem to be
self-liberating you are holding on to
something static ideas or memories
if you are holding an identity and idea
opinion judgment blame victimhood guilt
etc this will get in the way of
self-liberation
you can stop holding these stories by
deframing not reframing them
ultimately it's only when we totally
deframe and deconstruct our false views
that we wake up from the dream state of
separateness
fall in love with letting go of all the
mental structures you hold on to
amen
you'll hear us talk about that
a lot more
no idea form belief pattern identity is
true
absolute self-liberation
so we're talking about a heart full
emptiness
a full radiant emptiness something
radiant coming out of nowhere
true emptiness is radiantly alive i as a
separate identity don't really exist
nothingness becomes your reality
non-dual awareness is what you are
so that empty fullness is like the black
hole sun
we'll be making more content on that
soon
conditioned mine is always taking on
god's job wondering what people are
doing and why they do it but that is
none of your business none of your
concern you can just start walking
through life with this natural openness
to what is and be that way under all
conditions at all times that's what the
true self has been doing all along
openness has always been here
free yourself of all limiting identities
and embrace the infinite
return all the way to the seed
the seed contained the whole truth
here's another
visualization where you can
see that you have this
seed
winter emptiness
and then you have the springtime
flowering
infinite creation potentials
openness
and you guys can see we're passing by
quite a bit of profundity that is
highlighted that ajanti wrote about
and so again still
if you guys have insights on how to
optimally
distill out the essence of these
eventually at some point we may
also
undergo a process of
getting really strong animators on board
as well to help us with this that's in
the vision
and so that will be really helpful to
take the most profound things and then
animate them out
into
book videos
kind of like kirk's gaza in a nutshell
they're so good
so if you want to support us you can
find all the links in the bio below to
help fuel that effort join the channel
and all the goodies
thanks fam
course means asleep within the dream
state
course consciousness
you tell it's very coarse when it's
asleep in the dream state
real silence is your true nature you are
silence
there was only one state that was
totally natural and absolutely
effortless in that state i found access
to the deepest self which is freedom
it's a heartful quiet
stillness is not separate from motion or
movement stillness itself is moving
and that's what is ultimately
not to non-dual stillness itself is
moving
emptiest form form is empty
nothing and infinity infinity nothing
the true quiet is a brightness
you feel bright there is an awakeness a
deep sense of being alive
the nakedness of quiet or presence
disarms you so that you can't avoid any
experience any event anything
enter silence without being somebody
enter silence as nothing
nothing has reality until you reach it
grab it and somehow impregnate it with
the power of belief
but this nothing is actually the highest
price we ever pay it's our most sacred
commodity we will give our ideas our
beliefs our heart our body our mind and
our soul
the last thing that we'll give is
nothing
silence reveals itself only to itself
only when we enter as nothing and stay
as nothing will silence open its secret
its secret is itself
so true
and this is why this silence and doing
nothing and then allowing this
thought-free wakefulness to just arise
and to just be loving and be accepting
in the is-ness of what is
as
you're silent and not doing anything
and the cessation of discursive thinking
will naturally happen
but entering into that without being
somebody not like atlas is going to
enter emptiness no no no it's like i'm
already not that
it's emptiness that recognizes itself
silence is the final and ultimate
teacher in the final and ultimate
teaching it's the only teacher that
won't speak to you
silence is the ultimate and best teacher
because in silence
is the never-ending welcoming to do
that which our human heart truly desires
which is to always be with our knees on
the floor always be in that sort of
devotion to truth
silence is the only teaching and the
only teacher that is there all the time
every minute that you are awake every
minute that you are alive every minute
that you breathe
it's right there
telling you
adia love you brother
so strong
highly recommend
buying emptiness dancing and reading it
also buying the end of your world and
reading it you can also watch our review
video
on the end of your world on the channel
the price paid for consciousness to
become self-aware is almost always the
loss of true identity
consciousness loses itself
in what it created and identifies itself
with that creation this blip is called
the human condition
instead of being the entire ocean it
suffers under the hideous delusion that
it's just the wave on the surface of the
ocean
not wave
ocean
consciousness is liberated from the
mistake from false identification and
separation
it wakes up to the fact that it's really
not a wave but it's the ocean of being
it can then use that wave to deliver the
message to get other waves to
contemplate this possibility of
awakening
awake consciousness relates with
sleeping consciousness
this deep sleep is like the black hole
the emptiness
and then
in the waking state you're basically in
deep sleep you're in black hole in
emptiness and yet there's also sun
black hole sun
and that's the illumination the samadhi
of illumination along with the samadhi
of suchness and so you're illuminating
peace love joy bliss service
abundance prosperity healing compassion
into the field
non-attachedly non-fixatedly
you look back over your shoulder and bid
it goodbye as a nice experience
realizing something more mature is
coming
turn all your attention forward
resting and seeing everything as a whole
sky remembers that it's sky
consciousness
projects this thing called a human being
and gets so enamored with its creation
that it loses itself in it
just keep being what you are which is
nothing
then you realize this body mind
experiences whatever it experiences and
you are the conscious space for it to
have all those experiences it truly
doesn't matter what the experience is
the only way you can be really free is
by not fixating true maturity one of the
hardest things for spiritual people who
have had true and profound revelation
select
to go through
to accept the degree of surrender needed
to literally let go of all experience
and all self-reference
even in great revelations there is
almost always something that wants to
claim i am this every time you claim i
am this you just claimed another sense
perception thought emotion or feeling
when you go through this enough times
the mind gets
it on the deepest level and let's go
completely
you always know who and what you are
even though you can't define or describe
it or even think about it
you just know it by being it
this is the ultimate release of identity
and separateness
it realizes it can't find itself it
stops because it knows there's nothing
for it to do
it has stopped interpreting reality
then you're left with raw reality
without any distortion this is the
experience of deep liberating freedom
what does it really feel like to not
know
what you thought you were is what caused
all the problems
you come to know by not knowing simply
by resting in not knowing you know
the more you rest in not knowing which
means never grasping with the mind the
more your direct experience is that you
know
it comes in a flash
so good
so good
and that's why when we say
silence and do nothing and then
recognize the nature of mind essence
being empty cognizance
that arises
in a flash
recognizing true nature
true capital s self god realization
empty cognizance
nothingness and infinity
simply again by resting by not knowing
you know
the mind the body and the emotions play
this game called accumulation they
evaluate one piece of conceptual
knowledge against another piece of
conceptual knowledge
your awareness just goes right past that
wall of knowledge and moves into a very
quiet state
in this quietness you realize that you
don't know anything simply because you
aren't looking back to the mind for its
acquired knowledge
this quietness is a mystery to the mind
it is something unknown as you go into
depth you literally go into
a deeper experience of what seems to be
a great mystery
the mystery just keeps opening to itself
if you let it if you let go of control
so i'll play with
empty polymath
quite a bit here and
i'll make more content on it soon
covers both of the polls
in one
dissolve accumulations of knowledge
experience memory family friends lower
case s self
you are before all accumulations
so
lower case s self only existed in the
accumulation of knowledge and experience
literally leaving your memory behind
who are you when you are not thinking
yourself into existence
i love that
line who are you when you are not
thinking yourself into existence
this plays deeply in
douglas hofstetters i am a strange loop
as well
when you are not creating that
self-referential
coagulation
not simulating yourself into existence
space
when you are not thinking yourself into
existence
who you have taken yourself to be
literally isn't there anymore if this
you can disappear like that and reappear
as soon as you think it into existence
how real is it
the true i am is so unbelievably empty
it's so free of everything you thought
you were it has no limitation it has no
definition any definition
would be a disservice to what you are
all that's left is consciousness and
it's not even that because that's just a
word
true i am empty and free
be done with your eye
galaxy turns inward finds black hole
dissolves attachments
comes from pure being
those attachments are all those star
systems and planets
name
identity friends family likes dislikes
preferences
craving aversion
in this emptiness you start to taste the
experience of being this is being before
you are something or somebody this
mystery of being is what's awake and
alive
being is the one constant that which is
always awake
so you're transitioning from
the me self to the no self self
capital s
spiritual awakening
knowledge is still there
when you need it
nothing's
been lost except your false identity
so again from the me self lowercase s
to the no self capital s
self so this is eternal being appearing
as characters
there is only god
right i am that i am true awakened
knowledge
as soon as you are beyond
as soon as you are
being what you are nothing applies
anymore that's why so many of the great
spiritual teachers have said that there
is nothing to know
in order to be free in order to be
enlightened there is absolutely nothing
to know and there is no enlightenment as
long as you think you know something
as soon as you absolutely know that you
don't know anything and there is
absolutely nothing to know that state is
called enlightenment because all there
is is being
it's all one you see
that there is nothing to know
and your focus of inquiry shifts from
thought to being
so being has great wisdom
what a relief it is for the mind when it
no longer has to struggle and your whole
orientation spiritually speaking moves
from knowing to being
we manufacture this idea called the ego
to take the blame the ego doesn't really
exist
ego is only this interpretation this
movement of mind and that is why nobody
can find it
it's like a ghost
it's just a particularly conditioned
movement of mind
also called hungry ghost
in buddhism
from the
first link independent origination
when you become identified with that
lowercase s self
you're like a hungry ghost
egoing is not operating if we are not
becoming
it is the movement of becoming the
moving towards something or away from
something that stops
so
good everything arises spontaneously and
nothing has an inherent nature of me in
it
feel how completely disarmed the sense
of me feels it doesn't know what to do
that's the kind of stopping that's
important in that stopping a different
state of being an undivided state starts
to emerge
where there is no division there is not
the heavy restricted confined sense of
self you become a mystery
start on the level of being rather than
thinking
the mind finds there is no hook on which
to hang an identity so identity starts
to deconstruct itself in openness
the more identity deconstructs itself
the more alive and present we feel
yum
conditioning is like installing a
program in the mental computer
conditioning is without any self
when conditioning arises within a person
who is in an undivided state where he or
she neither takes ownership nor denies
it there can be a sacred alchemical
process through which the conditioning
reunifies itself all by itself
pure consciousness of being becomes
brighter and brighter and we realize who
we are this brightness is what we are
love transcends all experiences
creation is made of fierce love
openness meets openness
awake this love that transcends all
description when it is known as a deep
connection and deep unity this love is
indiscriminate it doesn't know how to
turn itself on and off
that switch
is only in the mind this love is always
on it loves saints and sinners equally
that's real love
imitation love is i love you more than i
love anyone else because you fit into my
little twisted world view better than
anyone else does
true love is synonymous with truth
love doesn't fall in and out love is
period
love meets itself in everything that
happens
it's the love simply for the fact that
there's anything happening at all
because that's the real miracle it could
so easily be that nothing exists
much easier to have nothing than
something it's a miracle that anything
happens and we live in this abundance
called life
love is indiscriminate
the only fear greater than death is love
real love
it is
a love of unity a love of seeing god
wearing all the masks and recognizing
itself in them all
real love is feared because it dissolves
separation conditioning
damn
so love is our shared being our
interdependent existence
so walls of opposition come down
naturally
a love that has no opposite
real love has no opposite
i remember at the shift into permanent
alignment retreat with bentino masaro
and the team in costa rica in
early 2021
that
this was written on the
bracelet
it's beautiful
you are holding an idea of your personal
boundary your edge and of course you
can't contain it love was never meant to
be contained
there is no drug more potent than
spiritual experience
this is the movement of the seeker but
it's also the movement of the me because
the meat is always interested in
opposite and equal reactions trying to
sustain one experience and avoid other
experiences that's what the me does it
chases after the good and avoids the bad
seeing that everything is one shoots a
hole in trying to pin the pendulum swing
of experience
so
so separation is seeking and we dissolve
the me into oneness so it's the me that
seeks and when you have no me that's
oneness
that's no seeking
pure being
so simple
love you fam so simple
i love this zen teacher
hold up his staff and say this is buddha
bang it on the ground
and everyone would think wow that's
really wild zen stuff
mic
is buddha
that's great
i love it
and those are the things that we do in
the mystic traditions is we
take this mind and we turn it on itself
and go beyond it
and these are the great little
koans and ways for us to do that
since it's not all one to the mind the
mind keeps looking for it where is it
what state is it
oneness simply means that everything is
the one
every experience that you will ever have
is the one
stops seeking a different experience
than the one that is happening right now
the secret dissolving and the peace
emerging the secret dissolves then the
peace is born and there is stillness
just this the center is always right
here the center always was right here
it's just the seeker that insisted the
center could be in the spiritual high
experience
in the center of it all there is no
seeker
right here there is nothing all is one
stretch break
fam
take some nice deep breaths
this is the great release the release
from having to change anything to get to
the promised land
or to search for the enlightened
experience the enlightened experience is
that nothing needs to change
this is the promised land this oneness
is god this is the one this is it it's
not somewhere else truth is infinitely
more free
there is nothing to seek there never was
anything to seek and that everything is
god is a big aha
deconstructionist technique of becoming
more free see through the misconceptions
that bind us disentangle them
progression movement is itself bondage
it is not freedom always waiting for the
next experience
butter melting
is like
moth into flame is the name of the game
as far as freedom goes there is really
no gauge to it
you're either awake or you're not
the comprehensive force alone is real
the world is the comprehensive force
that's non-duality
and i heard this quote is also
attributed to adi chankara
the world is illusory brahman alone is
real the world is brahman ramana
maharshi
and so
total non-duality
world views are self views literally
this world of perceptual overlay is not
actually happening except in the mind
all of these ideas are gone once the
brain stops ticking away it's not
actually here none of it is actually
happening that's why spiritual awakening
has an element of death
question the one who is holding the
beliefs is much more efficient
uprooting the one who is holding the
beliefs is what it is all about
who is the one who is holding this
belief
that's why i like asking the question
what is it that looks through your eyes
again deconstructing
self
if i pull the root out then the whole
conceptual structure collapses if you
leave a piece of the root it's going to
come back and start building again
yep
dissolve the one who asks
one minute you are a buddha the next
minute a sentient being
it is no mask emptiness
the first movement of emptiness is love
it leads to this whole universe the
creativity of this existence and the
birthing of it
true awakening if and only if you equals
buddha
in zen when the realization is deep your
whole being is dancing
you are dancing the emptiness is dancing
everything is alive again quiet very
pervasive love and a stillness that's
just deepening
and your gut is the oldest stability in
void
so realization becomes complete when it
hits on these three levels of head heart
and gut
the heart opens you dance the gut opens
it's a deep unfathomable stability of
you dying into transparency become the
absolute you are that
an empty transparent mountain
dancing
ah that's good stuff
die more completely dissolve all
self-protection of me
and the great death a total letting go
of everything
void
the mountain of emptiness which is the
substance actuality of existence
give up control absolutely totally and
completely then you would be a
spiritually free being
you were trying to control someone's
mind so that they would understand you
agree with you listen to you or like you
those who are liberated and free have
totally and absolutely let go of control
the desire for control feels as if there
is a clenched
hand in your gut
imagine what it would be like for the
desire to control to be completely
absent from your system
this desire to control is ultimately our
unwillingness to be fully awake
live free of the will to control
you are going to die
the biological sense that i'm going to
survive if i can control
final real freedom
a deep surrender
blind and unpredictable release of
control
there is no how just let
go
just let go
just let go
and know that this is all you and it's
all safe and it's all love
we'll let go together
as
a collective as a civilization
in our awakening to our oneness
yay
the final giving up of control
everything is unpredictable everything
is completely unknown
complete death of separate self control
into unpredictable unknown
i eternal life never die my bodies come
and go
me is a collection of familiar thoughts
always be absolutely totally and
completely coming from an honesty with
themselves a total internal integrity
hold with the integrity what is within
you
holding of integrity is what takes
people completely into truth
everything the questioner asks is a
means of tightening the grip only the
phonies don't get enlightened
hold surrendered void hold suchness
yay
they are coming from their heart and
they haven't sacrificed it for anything
or anybody
that's where everything is powerful
they are always people who had an
absolutely ruthless honesty and
integrity with themselves
it's rather rigorous for a human being
to do that because we usually run into
our own insecurities fears and doubts
there is no i at all and i is everywhere
yay
there isn't an i and the only thing that
exists is one big eye shining out of
everything
i love those so good
and that same simultaneity as no self
and capital s self or nothing and
everything emptiness and form infinity
and so things like this
they really do take you in a sense they
can take you all the way there
there's both no i
and everything is i
a radical no self
and a radical capital s self
these are all
different pointings to the same
end
and it's up to you to
identify
what is most resonant
and then
continue
deconditioning the sense of separate
self
with integrity and ruthlessness
because it doesn't [ __ ] exist anyway
so drop it
only the space that is awake remains
what you are is the only thing that you
cannot acquire
you can acquire everything but god
stop lying realize that you are god
look in your pocket look inside of you
and see if you don't see the exact same
gem
stop playing your familiar role
incredible mystery
that you will never figure out to be
this mystery consciously is the greatest
joy
your game will be gone
the separate self game is gone
[Music]
and then we have baby buddha
there's a little period with training
wheels for baby buddha
and be a little wobbly a little insecure
because if you're not willing to be
insecure you're going to go right back
to the old forms of self-protection and
seeking
nothing hides realization again so fast
as trying to figure it out
i love this suffering is one to five
percent pain hunger physical aches and
95 to 99
psychological like inner division
infinity
this kind of suffering happens because
one does not know one's true nature the
hallmark of knowing one's true nature
fully is to be undivided
the true self can't be divided but the
imaginary self can be divided
suffering that comes out of this
interior fracture
samsara is a completely mechanical
unfolding
of conditioning
so eloquent
so self equals suffering struggle
self is a verb not a noun
so you're selfing
when you stop selfing you stop
struggling and suffering so good he
stops samsara
so good
you are
is actually the absence of story
there is no self
so what you are is the absence of story
there is no self there is no story of me
the separate self is the source of all
struggle
freedom
certainly enlightenment has everything
to do with dying to what is it's very
simple enlightenment is nothing
more than the complete absence of
resistance to what is end of story
and it'll get tested a lot
and that's the beauty of it
and over time you just keep dying more
and more to what is absolute
non-resistance
so
self
is story
give up the separate character
there can't be any holding on to
self-image to points of view to ideas or
to identities enlightenment has no point
of view no agenda no center it simply
loves
there may still be a focal point in each
individual body but that is different
than thinking that the focal point is
the center of everything
compassion means a devotion to truth
the ultimate compassionate act is to
remove the center then there is only
freedom
spirit instead of the living incarnation
of a story
so surrender is giving up the story
self
and
wake up from the story of self
again self equal story
wake up from your story
you not only lose your center you lose
their center you can't see your true
nature without seeing the true nature of
everything
so surrender without an aim to gain
this is really important because when
you lose your center you see that
everyone loses their center
and that's when you know there's no
separation
it's when you know oneness
surrenders to give up our story about
ourselves
relieve me of self i want joy of no self
starting to see that our story is
fiction through and through this is the
awakening my god it's been a fiction
this is freedom
i love you guys
just take a moment to
if you have seen your story as fiction
your self
i me mine is fiction
congratulations it's beautiful
and if you have yet to
tune into this because this is where the
freedom is at
you're already it
just drop your story baby
let's drop your story
self less
equals no center no story
so there's a lot of people that have
self
central sense of self
and that
pedal the notion that they're selfless
that signal that to society
and so to truly be empty of self is the
greatest service
dissolve the storyteller is the
alleviation of suffering
dissolve the center
self is causeless love and peace
selfless is being without a self the
alleviation of the storyteller which is
the illusion of the me
right here is totally adequate
right here fam
right here drop the storyteller
drop the center drop the self
self is no longer seen as a problem this
is called the peace that surpasses all
understanding
everybody is the buddha jesus in
everyone this is actual concrete reality
only the oneness within can perceive the
oneness the me will never perceive
oneness
one being who sees the buddha in you is
worth more than reading 10 000 books
about the buddha
one being who actually knows that there
is only the buddha and that nothing else
is going on has a more powerful effect
than anything else
a compassion that does not seek to alter
anything paradoxically alters everything
an absolute non-resistance
hooked on the truth
the truth is what is most interesting to
me it is the only thing that is
interesting it is always fresh
amen brother
truth equals knowing nothing
what are you without your story
in the land of division there is always
something to know
but in enlightenment there isn't
anything to know enlightenment is
actually a process of unknowing
when you unknow everything
in the mind there is nothing left but
truth
truth unknowing absolutely everything
oui
see what i'm talking about fam look at
these pages with all these highlights
what can i say adia you crushed it
no description is necessary so just rest
on the edge on the precipice on the
direct experience directly feeling as
though you do not exist and yet knowing
that you do
one thought about this mystery sets
apart heaven and hell thought rips the
unity into pieces to be analyzed by the
mind but silence unifies the experience
of this moment is present but
ungraspable unknown but not definable
this that is awake cannot be caught
don't get lost in thought or you miss
your life
just simply relax and relax and relax
it's the simplest act of faith and trust
that which is awake in you so simple
just turn inward be like that which is
awake
in me that's it that's the mystery
that's truth it's oneness god
infinity nothingness
stay in the silence
and awakeness
this moment-to-moment choice is the fire
of truth
or you may by some grace by some good
luck realize that nothing in you wants
to sell out this that is awake anymore
not even for security or for the good
opinion of others it is a real grace to
realize this
never sell out awakeness
yay
this that's awake is the same for each
of us
if you don't see wholeness in everything
around you that's the continuation of
ignorance the continuation of violence
don't sacrifice this that is awake don't
think it out of existence don't bargain
it into the periphery of your life
human beings are coming from separation
not unity in 99 of the activities they
do
activity flowing from truth has such
potential every other motivation for
movement for action is violent
my experience of enlightenment was
simply the demolition of everything that
i thought it was going to be i have
never met anybody who has truly and
authentically awakened to the truth
ever say anything other than that
yeah enlightenment is
demolition it's the end of your world
seeking enlightenment what is the truth
asking what is the truth is a demolition
project most of spirituality is a
construction project
enlightenment is a demolition project
you cannot have a true thought about god
whatever you think about enlightenment
is also precisely and exactly what it's
not
the truth that we are avoiding is the
truth of emptiness we don't want to see
that we are nothing
we do not want to see that there is a
gaping void at the center of our
existence
and this was also from
one of our podcast conversations with
frank yang
frank was sharing with us that
everything we do is to avoid the
nothingness that we are
so avoiding void
infinite creation is avoiding void it's
fascinating
even in buddhism it is often covered up
though it is a little difficult
to hide the central tenet of the founder
there is no self even if it is not
hidden it's rarely talked about and when
it is it's kind of dressed up the real
teachings about enlightenment are like a
sword blade that swooshes right through
whatever direction you were going in
they cut your legs off and you find
yourself nose down on the floor bloodied
from the fall
the truly spiritual is i want only the
truth i'm willing to give up everything
that's not the truth i want the truth
which by its nature has to be that which
is not an acquisition an absolute
letting go there is nothing in
enlightenment for the me enlightenment
is realizing that there is no separate
self the taste of no separate self is
totally liberating
oneness is when there isn't another
oneness is
there is only this there is no that over
there there is only this and that's all
there is
there is only this and as soon as you
say what this is you've just defined
what it's not
this is only realized in the utter
demolition of everything that it's not
then
that awakening is an awakening outside
of everything that comes and goes it is
a total waking up outside of time
human beings don't know how significant
it is to wake up from a dream in the
middle of the night you literally woke
up out of a dimension that you took
to be just as true as this dimension
it's a cataclysmic change of
consciousness everything that i thought
was true in that dream ends up not being
true
when there is real and authentic
spiritual awakening the impact is
exactly the same it's the experience of
my god i took myself to be a human being
named so and so and i'm not and it's not
that i'm something bigger
or better or more expansive or more holy
or divine it means i'm not
period
and then i wrote this
don't panic it's just like waking up
from a dream
and i wrote this because
i got bedridden
for
a couple of hours over a couple of days
because
is yeah waking up from the dream of what
was
arkadzi alan sakyon and then became
atlas and then waking up from atlas
and so
it was
just quite beautiful
and it was also quite
like nervous system
just shocking
and this like that's where like this
panicky thing is it's like don't worry
don't panic it's just like waking up
from a dream
and that was calming
and it was really helpful
and so i hope this is
helpful
you took your atlas character to be real
and it's not that your costume on the
stage is not a beautiful firework of
infinity it absolutely is
but to know what underlies all costumes
is the essence of what enlightenment is
and so
go
recognize that and then you can also
enjoy your costume on this
stage in the play as well
you are it in all costumes
and the costumes come and go but you
don't
the self is what is there when there is
no self
that's what we were just talking about
there is only emptiness and its infinite
display of itself
freedom is the ultimate demolition
project because it steals everything
from you that's why it's liberating
the only thing that's ever looking at
emptiness is itself
you and i are rendered insignificant and
non-existent enlightenment wakes up
an illusion can't be enlightened
enlightenment steals everything from you
that's how you can spot enlightenment
whatever body it has happened through is
rob totally blind and it knows this but
it couldn't care less it is so happy to
be robbed blind
to not have all those points of view to
not believe the opinions of the mind
there is no way you could really see the
truth and not be giggling in some way
for the rest of your life there is no
way that you couldn't just love this
world to death
the mind starts to think it's being
handed candy when it's not it's being
handed a sword
do you know you are here to die into
oneness
an infinite singularity experiencing it
as
blank
you are perfect awake unity the source
of all
not the body mind
applied awakening there is no other all
is the one
after you awaken from the dream of
separateness and realize that you are
the source you need to discover the
implications of applying this revelation
to your life
when you re truly realize there is no
other than you it takes your breath away
all is one and you are the one
most people get so carried away
that they miss the true significance of
what has happened the revelation of
perfect oneness you are the ultimate
source a really clear perception of the
perfect unity that is actually inherent
in awakening
you are not the character in the dream
you are the dreamer
everything in the dream came from you
you are not the body mind
you are the ultimate source of the
entire dream you are the source of all
the implication inherent within
awakening
all the value of any true spiritual
revelation
is you are the ultimate source and
everything is perfect unity and
everything out there is actually you
equally so inherent in this revelation
of unity is the realization that there
is no such thing as another there is no
one else because it is all ultimately
one's own self
so all is the dreamer
you
the dreamer
how it could change your life if you
have the revelation that there is no
other and you get very curious about the
implications what if you asked what does
this mean for me for the rest of my life
how can you be free if there is no
personal i who is there to be
enlightened
you wake up out of this me and you there
is no personal relationship there is no
other
awakening is like a personal experience
of the big bang
realization is always a perfect
destroyer
throw your life into truth
uncover the deepest realization that
there is no other the realization itself
rearranges how this dream of appearances
operates
there is no such thing as a personal
relationship between a you and a me to
make the relationship better just wake
up more
wake up more
you don't need a teacher to explain the
implications of there being no other you
need to do that for yourself
completely wake up only be interested in
truth dream state of separateness and
all its guises will not interest you you
are the dreamer pulling all the strings
transcendent dreamer is the one who
creates the dream of the world
and conditioning can pull you back into
the dream
spiritually speaking
the question
what am i is the question that goes
right to the heart of things
the infinite intelligence is actually
what you are but you have to be serious
enough to find out for yourself what is
true
there is only the one manifesting as
everything
there is only the one manifesting as
everything there is no other realization
is always a perfect destroyer
when we sit as our true self then we are
just
sitting as no self image no self concept
no self idea we are just sitting as
spaciousness
the real groundwork of dharmic
relationship is relationship with that
mystery with our own self
you start to perceive directly that all
of manifestation no matter what it is is
the flowering of the divine you start to
see the same sacredness everywhere the
same intimate dharmic relationship of
the mystery to itself
and so it goes more and more deeper and
deeper penetration
and into more areas
as you perceive the sacredness in all
things you know you are not who you
thought you were you are an alive awake
mystery that can't be touched or seen
anything that is unmet or unseen will be
like a little button with a push me
sticker on it and it attracts fingers
that's the beauty of the sacredness
cannot stay unconscious there is the
opportunity how interesting what is that
but what is it what is this
so it's like the more awake
the push is the unconscious buttons of
the less awake and their awake openness
enables transformative alchemy
the light of awakeness itself is the
deepest transformative agent and the
deepest alchemy takes place in the
willingness to stay conscious to our own
unconsciousness
just stay awake when those buttons get
pushed and then the alchemy happens
love is always throwing itself into the
moment here and now fully abandoning
itself into now
our button its own unconsciousness
the more conscious you get the harder it
is to maintain division if you are going
to be totally conscious relating from
division is not an option so it's
literally impossible to be fully awake
and not be awake everywhere
there's the invitation what is that and
what's my relationship with that
see the oneness everywhere in every
experience
even when the idea collapses the reality
of the sacred has an opportunity to
emerge and the real sacred is much more
beautiful than the idea not as dramatic
but much more beautiful the dharmic
relationship is relating with all from
oneness non-separation no other truth to
truth mystery to mystery love to love no
hiding [ __ ]
where you
want nothing where you are nothing meet
only mystery to mystery
this is always already what is longed
for freedom appearing
now is outside of time there is no time
and the paradox is that the only thing
that keeps you from seeing the eternal
is that your mind is stuck in time so
you miss what's actually here
every time you come here you are nothing
radiantly nothing absolutely and
eternally zero empty nest that is awake
emptyness that is full emptiness that is
everything
the freedom is my god there is nobody
here to be enlightened therefore there
is nobody there to be unenlightened
that's the light
in a moment of seeing through the
conceptual me and realizing it is just
mind activity you know there is nobody
to be enlightened
who am i without the story
you put down the book called my life you
see that there is no story and there is
no me the me is a story the whole story
springs spontaneously out of nothing out
of spirit for its own enjoyment it
exists for you to read it laugh a little
cry a little have ups have downs have
lives have deaths have friends have
enemies but never to be taken seriously
you are off the page
there is just awareness outside of the
story
but don't worry the story will go on it
keeps going even without the me movement
continues
god is like a flame it's alive ever
moving and ever dancing flame is
impermanent truth is continuous movement
this movement this aliveness of truth is
constant it never ceases it is timeless
impermanence is the only continuous
thing the only permanent thing
you can see that even though you are
moving very fast inside the train is
absolutely still and it feels as if you
aren't moving at all the stillness of
being is just that way what we call
permanence is endless
resistanceless motion
aliveness of this moment
is experienced free of resistance it's
totally still and it's totally moving
the flame it can't grab itself it can
only be itself
the undulating moving heart in union
with itself
and this is where you can synthesize
uh
heraclitus
and parmenidus so heraclitus
of transience
of
impermanence of becoming
and the parmenidus of eternity
permanence being
there is an absolute base in the heart
where there is emptiness this is the
place before the truth becomes alive
before it leaps out into existence where
distinction never gazed
to be freedom you have to have an
absolute fidelity to truth
we can be relaxed
and also
open-hearted available and really
present when we do this the implication
for how relationship unfolds is profound
to be free the human has to be committed
to truth forever
the fierce fidelity to truth is not
something to be taken lightly
one broken vow with the truth sets
heaven and earth infinitely apart
the most sacred vow of all the vow to
love openheartedly the vow of the
deepest surrender of the heart
vulnerable with your heart just be
present don't live from your conditioned
mind lift from unconditional truth the
truth loves it does not judge it holds a
big sword in its hands and can
ruthlessly discern what is false and
what is true
the thread of love running through every
single moment there was never a victim
not even for a moment
close the gap between what is and what
you want it to be
lean into life into the moment and into
the richness of what is
eons of conditioned webs of love for you
the one to have this beautiful
experience of life
fullness of the emptiness
it comes out of nothing just like the
flower that's not even there one day and
shows up the next
then i say then say i am going away but
where could i go the flower will die but
life is just fine thank you expression
goes insights go personalities change
beliefs change you remain
everything changes you
god remain
so adhyashanti
grew up as an overall happy experience
in childhood had an early attraction to
spirituality
i loved this interview with him in the
back it's nice
i could sense that everything was one
thing it felt like something different
was looking through my eyes something
totally mysterious and very ancient and
eternal
what was looking through my eyes really
wanted to look at things very closely
and intently if i looked too long at
people it would shock them
i've had that experience a couple times
i was looking
through the eyes of eternity
something was looking that felt really
ancient and yet really young and
innocent at the same time
that's what it feels like
so well said
this life is not mine it belongs to this
enlightenment thing
i don't even have a choice anymore
i felt very viscerally that it was in
control same thing
from the very beginning what i got
interested in was what does the
enlightenment thing have to do with the
truth or ultimate reality that is what i
was fueled by i woke up one morning and
thought nothing else in my life makes
sense unless i find out what is going on
here
yeah adi and i have a lot of similarity
i was totally absorbed with the quest
for enlightenment
inward explosion
i just became space
downloaded into me so quickly
i've been chasing what i already was
that's the first
awakening you little son of a [ __ ]
this isn't it keep going
there's more to this you haven't seen
the whole thing you've seen a very
significant part but keep going don't
stop here
trying to become what i knew i already
was
i was what i was seeking i knew that i
am what i am seeking i am this truth
what is this i am it i know i am it but
i don't know what it is
and so so seeking is like
i am it
first awakening and the second awakening
is
what is it and the question dissolves
it was about some remnant of a
self-image i was simply perpetuating my
old self-image it felt so good to be rid
of that persona it felt very liberating
intelligence takes over and pulls all of
us through whatever we need to go
through to
get us to let go
who am i without
interviewing and show
simulation
total freedom
artistically expressing as the wind
moves
falseness was torn out of me bit by bit
b space in a simple human way
awakening comes on the heels of these
tearing out experiences
pull to go inside
i'm ready
who hears the sound it was just one
there was zero identity in the
thought love it
the one light
behind all form costumes of clothing
this that was awake knew immediately
that i had been trapped in those images
what we might call incarnations i was
asleep in those images it wasn't trapped
in those anymore
just this awakeness completely
only itself no form no name no shape no
color no nothing no location but
everywhere
this awakeness was everything
the body was happening
within that awakeness or spirit
the body was in it rather than i was in
the body
it took
occupancy without confusion this time
without any identification
you don't think that you are your
clothes they're just something you wear
it was just so clear that this form that
this particular personality this guy
formerly known as stephen gray
that this was clothing this is his
current incarnation this thing that he
is going to wear and function through
wow this is so cool child like joy felt
like being a baby every step was the
first step everything was new and
everything had this sense of intimacy
and wonder and appreciation
this is a miracle this is life this body
this is heaven
as messy as it is as silly as it is as
wonderful and terrible as it is this is
you know the great joke walking in god's
hand looking for god
nothing extraordinary needs to happen in
my life anymore just existing is a sort
of miracle
i realized what i am in a totally clear
way there wasn't another question left
to be answered spiritually
so what you were seeking was you number
one and number two what is this
it's an impossible question to answer
the funny thing is the answer to the
question is that the question disappears
that's the answer to the question it's
not like you get a nice answer that you
can put in your pocket
the more we know what we are the more we
know that
what we are is something that by its
very nature can never be known
perfect
you know what
you are but you know that you are a
mystery
you end up knowing that you are what you
can never know
there's no definition you notice it's
just i am that's the mystery declaring
itself that's it
the intellect can actually play an
important part in spiritual awakening
a book carries the transmission of the
consciousness or presence of its author
there's a meeting that's really the
transmission emptiness meets emptiness
we need to become responsible for our
own transformation
being in the presence of somebody might
light a fire spontaneously but you
yourself have to tend that fire
we love you audi ashanti thank you so
much
who are you when you are
not thinking yourself into existence
when the realization is deep
your whole being is dancing
three levels head
heart and gut an enlightened mind and
then the heart dances
and then the gut opens up and there's a
deep deep unfathomable stability
you died into transparency and emptiness
is dancing
thank you
brother adiasanti
what a beautiful book you're an
incredible
spiritual synthesis and distiller and
we're
so grateful for you thank you
thanks fam thanks everyone for tuning in
and listening
i hope that this brought you a lot of
value a lot of insight a lot of
self-realization
a lot of
dissolving of conditioning and ego and
separation a lot of unity a lot of
oneness
a lot of equanimity peace joy
prosperity abundance
childlike
innocence sage-like wisdom
and if so i would love for you to like
the video
help the algorithm out also subscribe to
the channel if you haven't yet
also
leave a comment below with your thoughts
on emptiness dancing your
favorite takeaways would love for you to
write those below as well
if you have any ideas on how to improve
these book distillation videos we'd love
to hear from that you about that as well
and also share this video
of this distillation of emptiness
dancing with your friends families
co-workers people online
and get the good word out so we can
ignite that global awakening baby
that's all fam
i'm excited for you to see what we have
coming up for a couple more of these
distillation videos
we have so much other epic content
coming we've had a lot of great recent
interviews on the channel as well check
those out if you haven't yet
that's all
namaste bow to the divine in you
and the great perfection that this is
always and forever
thank you adiasanti
thank you fam
infinite love
and of course
you can find the link
to adi ashanti's website
and also
the
book
in the bio below
check it out